what is the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to you
to me yeah
okay so i was
eating this girl out just
chilling in a room
and all of a sudden it just she started
bleeding and when i i was done my whole
face was covered in blood
so yeah that was that i guess
yeah i mean
it's not embarrassing for me i guess but
like it was awkward
ah you guessed no no i mean
it just
it was it wasn't the first time it was
so i mean i don't know every single
thing they said redmond's amazed when i
was on a plane and i smoked burning
at the back of the plane and i thought
the plane was sitting a light at the
back when actually they was just cooking
the food and now got up and started
screaming
saying the plane's on fire and it
weren't they were just starting cooking
the food at the moment screaming really
loud
yes when i got off that plane i was like
uh i felt so embarrassed um i guess
there have been many but one of the one
that was pretty this day was when i fall
from the
from a bed when i was sleeping and i
started screaming
and it was such a
such a
it was such like it was so confusing for
me to understand but i wasn't in my
dream or it was so the year such as
kundalini i just started screaming was
it was it was there someone else in the
room yes we were three people in the
same room then other two need to come
and help me out because i just got so
frozen i could not even pick myself up
yes i was
when i fall down it was my park on the
floor so it was oh and it's my head how
high was it uh
i guess it's like when you have a double
uh you when you have a double a bed and
when you have the the top one and then
when you fall it's so embarrassing and
it's very painful as well did you know
them well at least yes that's the reason
they helped me oh they would have just
started laughing at me
i was sitting on the sofa and i don't
know what came into my mind and i
decided to jump on the bed and i was
just stood on the sofa and i jumped on
the bed but i missed it and because of
that i just fell down and i twisted my
ankle and i was sitting with my cousins
and all no one came for my help they all
were laughing
[Music]
i was laughing because i thought it's
just minor but in the morning i got to
know i broke my bone and all and i got
fractured
but it was embarrassing at that point
because i thought i would jump nicely or
something but i couldn't i'm trying to
breathe
but i couldn't and i fell down and i
twisted my ankle and and all were
laughing we all were laughing but it was
embarrassing for me inside but i was
laughing outside